en colombia solo hay un partido político
que no necesita votos para llegar al
congreso el acuerdo de paz firmado en
2016 les garantizo a los entonces
miembros de la antigua guerrilla de las
farc 10 de las 280 curules legislativas
5 en cada cámara para facilitar su
transición a la vida política después de
medio siglo de conflicto armado llamada
anteriormente fuerza alternativa
revolucionaria del común y hoy partido
comunes de esta colectividad forman
parte de unos 7.000 ex combatientes no
ha sido fácil puesto que quienes
asumimos las posiciones como era normal
de dirección venimos desde una
experiencia de la lucha armada que hemos
tenido que estar luchando por
la implementación integral del acuerdo
en una
un pulso muy duro muy muy
tenso con este gobierno en medio de un
problema que yo diría que es el más
difícil que nosotros hemos enfrentado en
este proceso y en la estigmatización
permanente pero su protagonismo en la
escena política está en riesgo de
desvanecerse los acuerdos de paz
establecieron que los escaños serían
asegurados sólo por dos legislaturas en
la próxima elección en 2026 el partido
comunes deberá conseguir su propio
respaldo popular si quiere conservar
asientos en el congreso una tarea nada
fácil después de un tímido debut en 2018
con apenas 90.000 votos para las dos
cámaras de los cuales 50.000 fueron para
el senado una pequeña fracción de lo que
hubiera requerido para ganar curules la
labor se ha vuelto más difícil no sólo
por los más de 300 ex combatientes
asesinados desde 2016 sino también por
las fracturas que ha sufrido el partido
desde su propio nacimiento por un lado
el estado colombiano en su conjunto no
ha cumplido lo pactado de manera
integral como hemos dicho pero en
términos políticos en lo que corresponde
con la dirigencia
firmante del acuerdo de paz de la
insurgencia pues también hay falencias
enormes pues estos señores no sé no se
han adaptado a que estamos en la vida
civil que estamos construyendo un
partido donde hay debate donde hay
distintas opiniones y que hay que buscar
consensos muchas gracias en la elección
de este año el número de votos será un
buen termómetro sobre los cerca o lejos
que está de conseguir por sí misma los
apoyos que necesita dentro de los cuatro
años la otrora guerrilla más antigua del
continente